between movies TV shows and of course
comics there's more superhero media than
ever and unfortunately for our favorite
comic book characters that comes with a
pretty high body count they might come
back after a few years but in the
meantime we're taking a moment to
remember their loss from obscure
alternate universes to shockingly
short-lived movie stars and all the way
to everyone's favorite super-powered dog
here are some superheroes we've lost in
2018 half of the Avengers let's talk
about the Thanos in the room Avengers
infinity war ended with the darkest
cliffhanger in Marvel history it's
devastating and much more horrific than
the comic book source material where
people just blinked out of existence
on the big screen they feel what's
coming before it hits and they're slowly
erased inch by inch until there's
nothing left by the time the credits
roll we watched Bucky Falcon Scarlet
Witch Black Panther spider-man roots
star-lord Drax mantis and Doctor Strange
all get erased from reality in the films
one and only post-credit scene we see
similar faiths befall Maria Hill and
Nick Fury with sequels and the works for
many of these heroes it's a safe bet
that not all of these dusty deaths will
stick but if they do get reversed it
won't likely be until next year's
Avenger sequel and we won't know until
then who will come back and who won't
the mighty scrag in 2017 venom verse the
Marvel multiverse was introduced to an
alien race called the poisons who were
hunting down Venom symbiote from
alternate realities this year they hit
Marvel's earth in an event called venom
eyes and set their sights on mighty
scrag scrag was a product of kid kazoo a
super-powered inhuman introduced during
the monsters unleased crossover who had
the power to summon gigantic monsters by
drawing them
scrag one of Caillou's creations was an
insectoid giant who became infected by
the poison during their invasion
scrag went on a rampage and while the
infection could be stopped by the
symbiote based hero anti-venom removing
the parasites from him had lethal
consequences
without any choice the heroes did what
they had to do and scrag died but not
before telling kid Kai's you that he
loved him Hey when I crying you're
crying
Robert bring the six-part miniseries new
challengers is a reimagining of the
Silver Age challengers of the unknown
unlike earlier incarnations of
characters however the quartet in this
series aren't super heroic adventurers
instead they're essentially post-mortem
prisoners Trina Alvarez Moses barber
Robert brink and a big guy who goes by
crunch all appear before a mysterious
benefactor called prof and are told they
all just died before he can get any
further into explaining the premise
though one of the challengers dies
before he even goes on his first mission
robert frank gets a little too impatient
and hops in a portal and immediately
begins to melt
whenever the challengers leave their
base of operations known only as the
mountain they're on borrowed time and if
they're gone too long they'll share
brings fate seconds after his death we
meet his replacement Bethany Hopkins
with that we get our actual team of new
challengers who will probably listen a
little more carefully than poor Robert
x-force in spite of being featured in
the trailers for Deadpool to bedlam was
the first member of x-force to kick the
bucket and didn't even get a chance to
throw a punch before it happened played
by Terry Crews bedlam is part of the
x-force team the Deadpool puts together
for a high stakes airdrop into a prison
convoy when high speed winds blow them
off course the entire roster of x-force
aside from Deadpool and Domino are
killed and bedlam blown face-first into
a bus in the darkly hilarious carnage
that followed the most surprising death
was shatter star a longtime x-force
member in the comics shatter star was
heavily featured in the trailers but
sadly wound up on the wrong end of a
helicopter and got chopped to pieces
moviegoers didn't even get to see his
cool swords they have two blades
next was the Vanisher he was one of the
x-men's earliest comic book villains but
when he showed up or didn't in Deadpool
- no one was really sure if Telford
Porter the teleporting mutants with what
might be the worst name in comics
history actually existed eventually
though
it turned out he was a full-fledged
member of the team and moviegoers got a
glimpse at just who was behind his less
than visible presence we actually got to
see the Vanisher just as he was being
electrocuted with the unmistakable face
of Brad Pitt in the comics zeitgeist is
the leader of a reality show Celebrity
version of x-force who dies on the same
issue where he makes his first
appearance so with nothing else
Deadpool too has that bit of accuracy to
its source material going for it also
accurate his extremely gross superpower
of barfing acid which we only get to see
as he dies in a woodchipper x-men
origins Deadpool x-men origins Wolverine
is often considered a low point for
Deadpool fans mostly because it turned
the famously talkative Wade Wilson into
a mouth less murderous Mortal Kombat
ripoff as much as you may hate that
movie Ryan Reynolds has shown us that he
probably hates it more parodying that
movie's action in Deadpool - if that
wasn't enough he proved it once and for
all in the mid credit sequence of
Deadpool - when he used cable's
time-travel device to go back and fire
bullet after bullet into the earlier
version of himself Flash Thompson the
800th issue of amazing spider-man
brought fans a climactic battle between
spider-man and Norman Osborn who had
bonded with the carnage symbiote to form
the red Goblin Osborn waged war on Peter
Parker the way he always had by going
after spider-man's friends and family
fortunately Flash Thompson Peters high
school bully turned close friend was
there to help with his abilities as the
hero anti-venom
using his power to neutralize shards of
the carnage symbiote that Osborn had
left behind in Aunt May Mary Jane and
Spidey's other loved ones his help came
with a cost though when anti-venom
foiled Osborne's contingency plans the
red goblins retribution was Swift and
lethal the human dynamo in Deathstroke
number 32
Slade Wilson goes to war with fat
but unsurprisingly neither one of them
is the one who dies instead the Dark
Knight tries to stop Wilson from
assassinating his latest target an
obscure hero named ace Masterson the
human dynamo the twist it was actually
Masterson himself who hired Deathstroke
due to worries about the onset of
dementia that would make him too
dangerous to live with his explosive
powers rather than find out for himself
he hired Deathstroke to help him go out
in a blaze of glory
Batman tried to stop the hit from
happening but eventually Deathstroke
just shot master set in the head pretty
grim for a guy who used to be on a team
called the Justice experience Sinestro
Sinestro isn't often considered a hero
but in the ongoing comics tying to the
injustice video games
the former villain rejoined the Green
Lantern Corps just in time to fail
protecting OA from an assault by the
Atrocitus the red lanterns and a
possessed Green Lantern Corps in
injustice to number 64 and just to make
things a little bit worse he was killed
by his own daughter ceramic who then
took up Sinestro's ring as his
replacement
Triton a series with the title like
death of the Inhumans is bound to
contain its share of dead superheroes
and the first came from Triton one of
the original Inhumans who first appeared
in 1965 while investigating a group of
slaughtered Inhumans who were murdered
by their alien creators the Kree Triton
discovers a bomb hidden in a corpse
while the rest of the Inhumans are able
to teleport safely Triton's not so lucky
he was the first inhuman killed in the
series but he would not be the last
lockjaw lockjaw is arguably the most
beloved of all Inhumans for good reason
he's the goodest boy in the whole Marvel
Universe come on who doesn't love a
giant teleporting dog the answer it
seems is a super human named Vox the
villain behind death of the Inhumans who
has the powers of every other inhuman
and wants nothing more than to destroy
their whole group and their very large
dog
- after lockjaw rescues the often
villainous Maximus the mad from Vox the
two of them make
final stand before they're vaporized
when box uses black bolts devastating
voice to destroy them
hank pym and the van dines while most of
ant-man and the wasp takes place before
the events of Avengers infinity war the
post-credits scenes caught up to the
Avengers battle with Thanos in those we
learned that the original ant-man and
both women who went by the codename
wasps were victims of Thanos's infamous
snap leaving Scott Lang floating in the
quantum realm with what appears to be no
way out Booster Gold only two issues
after Sinestro died defending OA
injustice to number 66 claimed another
hero's life in its cosmic war this time
though it wasn't a casualty that the
good guys thought it would be
while Blue Beetle was prepared to
sacrifice his life to stop star Oh
Booster Gold made a last-minute switch
to keep the younger hero alive the last
thing he saw was the second Blue Beetle
Ted Kord Ted had previously died himself
but was brought to booster side by
time-travel so that the two best friends
could see each other in boosters final
moments the challengers of the unknown
things in the miniseries new challengers
didn't take long to get pretty
complicated and the old-school
challengers of the unknown fell victim
to one of those complications see if you
can follow this one new challengers
number two ended with the original team
confronting their successors and
shooting their leader prop in the head
since one of the original challengers is
named froth they assumed this new one
was an impostor but he turned out to be
a prof. from another dimension with the
surprising ability to recover from being
shot in the head to make matters even
more complicated
the original challengers then
encountered someone who they thought was
the new prof only to find a third prop
who turned out to be a murderous
cybernetic mummy did you get all that no
that's okay
just remember prof is dead long live the
other props blood storm hailing from an
alternate reality where she was bitten
by Dracula blood storm is a vampiric
version of the x-men's weather
controlling storm more recently she's
been serving on the team in the core
universe but unfortunately this led to
her fighting against the mutant hunting
a hab in the pages of extermination
a hab came prepared to taking blood
storm with a silver harpoon that he
brought just in case a vampire x-man
showed up
it might seem unlikely that someone
would make preparations for that exact
eventualities but hey it's the Marvel
Universe that's the sort of thing that
happens a lot cable the second mutant to
fall an extermination was cable he was
executed by a mysterious hooded figure
who traveled back from the future
twist it turned out that cables killer
was a younger leaner version of cable
himself who has his sights set on the
time-traveling original five x-men Nakia
fans of the MC you may remember Nakia as
two challahs love interest in 2017 s
black panther where she was played by
Lupita and yong-go but in the comics
she's very different character
Nakia was one of the first of the dora
melash a that readers met in 1998 s
black panther number one eventually
thanks partly to some meddling from the
demonic Mephisto Nakia became obsessed
with T'Challa and eventually left the
dorm illogic becoming a villain called
malice powered by a mystical earth in
the Wakanda forever event we learned the
continued exposure to the herb that gave
her powers is slowly killing Nakia in
Wakanda forever Avengers number one
Nakia is reunited with the dora milosz a
to defeat a wakandan weapon called mimic
27 that created doppelgangers of
superhumans she convinced it to let go
of the hatred it felt for her sisters it
managed to release that same hatred from
herself before succumbing to the herbs
effects she died but was buried with
honor among the other Fallen Dorabella J
[Music]